hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so i'm back to france guys
i'm back from panama i traveled a lot
the past three days my flight got
cancelled
i got stuck in the airport guest for 24
hours it was not funny at all and what
was even less funny is that when i
arrived and i checked the market guys i
saw amc getting destroyed so um that's
not looking good we're gonna have a look
at everything that is happening i'm
gonna today start with gme by the way
and i want to show you some cool things
on other stocks as well because once
again my investment strategy consists of
making money on the rest of the market
that is kind of easier and then to put
this money in what i really believe in
amc gme so let's start right now okay
guys so let's get into it we're gonna
start with gme uh like i said in my
previous video i got some complaints
of members saying you always spend so
much time on amc and so little time on
gme and
and that's true guys because my my
community you guys uh has been built on
amc so this is the reason why i usually
talk more about amc
but in today's video i wanna focus on
jme and i'm gonna i'm gonna start uh the
analysis on jme first then of course i'm
gonna do amc um so
let's have a look at the global
situation first so jimmy had a breakout
guys here it was on march bam bam bam 28
very good memories when i was in panama
i was live guys during this
massive massive breakout that occurred
on increasing volume which is very
important guys and i'm going to show you
once again what we are looking for right
now on amc uh but let me finish on jamie
first
so we had this breakout whenever we have
a breakout like that
uh without a nice consolidation before
okay as you can see here this breakout
occurred from the lows okay it's not a
breakout that occurs
after the press action you know knocked
out the door several times which in this
case means we have a lot of energy and
that we can push higher right away here
we arrived a bit extended all right we
arrived in a fifth wave the breakout
didn't occur in the third wave it
occurred in the fifth wave at the end of
the fifth wave so whenever we have this
kind of
breakout usually they last they hold
which means that uh we have just that
this is only the beginning of something
bigger
um
and we usually come back this is what i
was using guys on the mc
uh
to
some fib ratios so we never know which
fib ratio is going to be hit and where
we gonna find support uh what i have
what i know from my experience is that
second waves they usually like to go to
the 61.8
ratio because second waves are you know
at the very beginning of something new
so bears are still you know quite active
uh whereas force waves which occur at
the end of a move up usually only go to
the 38.2 percent retracement because uh
bulls are in full control after the
third wave and uh bears won't try to
sell uh very deep in this force wave
pullback so here we don't have a false
wave pullback yet the fourth wave
pullback would happen
here maybe once again guys
this scenario is a scenario that i
personally believe a lot in but uh i
have no clue if it will happen um it's
just something that makes sense to me
when i look at the uh past press action
so this false wave could happen around
300 we're not there yet for now we're on
the second wave uh and once again second
wave sometimes they only go to the 38.2
percent fib ratio
for example if you look at tesla if you
look at bitcoin if you look at those
assets that got inflated a lot in the
past one two years
whenever we have some strong strong
moves up that are stunning
you can see i've done that several times
you can do it by yourself you can see
that second waves usually only go to the
38.2 so this is the reason why when i
see a massive move up that is starting i
like to start buying at the 38.2 percent
fib ratio once the first wave is
complete to know that the first wave is
complete is not very difficult to just
look for some strong moves down uh that
happened after some massive moves up all
right so this is a second wave
correction once again a second wave
correction sometimes is not gonna give a
third wave and in that case it won't be
a one two three four five we're gonna
discuss that maybe this is what is
happening on amc for now on gme is
looking still very good
because as you can see we have an rsi
above 50 51.9
i like to keep always rsi and maximum
charts basically a macd you can check
the macd signal very basic information
that is telling you if we are bullish or
bearish here um the macd sigma has
turned red in the e on friday so this
was not a good thing but we still have
an rsi above 50. if the rsi comes below
50 then we're gonna have bearish signals
coming from uh both
oscillators which are momentum
indicators macd and rsi for now we have
mixed signals coming from here if i look
at the fields we are above the 61.8
which is at 123 so we are still looking
uh very good for a second wave
um
i'm going to zoom in and show you what
is happening in the short term but first
let me finish here we have the 38 to 153
we had some reaction here once twice
three and then it was acting as
resistance let me zoom in and see that
more clearly guys
um
so yeah 38.2 was the first support level
as you can see it acted perfectly as
support one two three four five reaction
and then it was a resistance okay guys
and i was here i told i gave you this
level before so um i'm telling that
because
um
because for the past five seven days my
analysis on the uh bigger picture on amc
is off and i need to you know recognize
that but uh it's still interesting to
see that the levels i'm giving you guys
are acting very well as support and then
once they're broken as resistances i'm
saying that because right now on gme
we're higher uh but we're a bit in the
same situation we are dropping so this
is the reason why i want to show you
where are the support and resistances
level
and here we have one that is very
obvious when i go on the hourly
timeframe let me remove the flip so we
see more clearly
uh let me just check if this is working
well because guys i recorded this video
once already i needed to do it again so
i hope this time is gonna work well
um so anyway so 141.8
is a clear support guys and you can have
a look how many reactions we get here
one two three four five six seven eight
nine it's the ninth reaction we have at
this level so this is what we call a
consolidation the price action and this
is what we need on the amc by the way
i'm going to show you that very soon the
price action is consolidating around 141
it's not around it's consolidating just
above the 141.8 level and has been
tested multiple times so yes this is um
unfortunately scenario for uh
continuation uh on on the contribution
move on the same
in the same direction so here on the
downside so maybe we're gonna go 230
i don't know if you're going to do that
i'm just saying that if you have a
breakout with volume increase for now
look at the volume the volume is very
low exactly like it needs to be during
consolidation if you have a bracket
below that level it won't be looking
good but it will still be looking on the
short term but you it would still be
looking very good on the
medium or long term not sure how i could
i should call that because we are still
far far above uh the areas where bears
uh you know where this bullish momentum
started uh two three weeks ago will
fade totally so um for now we're looking
good i don't know which fib ratio is
going to be the right one
i know that 142 is now support it is
holding well but if we break it with
volume we're probably going to go 230 uh
then we still have the 125 level that is
the uh 61.8 fib ratio so another
interesting thing so for now to conclude
bullish or bearish we are neutral guys
uh between 120 and 160 uh bulls are
still totally in control on the longer
term uh even if we start to have mixed
signals coming from the macd and rsi
we
are still
benefiting from this breakout that is
holding for now guys which is a
beautiful breakout we don't see perfect
breakouts often it's not a perfect one
because the consideration was happening
much lower but it's still a very
beautiful breakout that happened here
guys
and we are still whenever a breakout
happens through a resistance the
resistance becomes support and as you
can see so here the resistance is this
trend line that is an inclined trend
line that is here guys connecting the
highs using a regular scale
um
and as you can see we are we were
sliding
above the streamline then it got broken
and now we are a little bit below so
this is not a very good sign this
consolidation that is happening between
142 and this trend line uh i don't know
which direction the market will take but
what i can tell you guys is that
from what i see
compared to the rest of the market we
have the inflation number that arrived
today 8.5 percent guys uh that's not
good we're expecting 8.4 uh we still
have this war you know between russia
and ukraine that is by the way creating
this inflation but that is also bad for
business more generally speaking it's
creating tensions between countries so
it's not good we have the fed policy
that is uh that needs to increase the
rates to tackle inflation and we don't
have an amazing growth
because of this lack of
business due to the war
uh so the situation is not good and
despite this fact we can see how
strongly gme is uh holding guys very
high after this first move up so i'm
still here of course very bullish once
again i don't know what's going to
happen but
i can tell you that 142 support the next
support is 130 and that was still
looking good as long as we are above
those levels um now i wanted to tell you
that guys uh to quickly talk about the
global market i will also show you uh
some other trades that i did in the past
two days guys where generated some good
money uh because i just want to make it
clear i mean for those who are not with
me in this code and then you know just
watch my video i always talk about amc
and jimmy because this is what you guys
want to see this is how my channel has
been built and i just want to give you
what you guys want to uh to to hear and
to um to watch the analysis you wanted
to see so this is the reason why i'm
always gonna talk about those two but
there are many other stocks that i of
course use my techniques that is that
are working much better here i have to
be honest uh so i was expecting this
first wave to go to 32 here i was
correct
um and then i was expecting a second
wave pull back going to 26 below 26 and
21. we went beyond 21
as you can see here and
really getting brutally hammered guys so
that's not
good for a second wave okay even if it
happens on no volume we don't like to
see such you know um
like like a strong move down that is so
perfect yes it's not look it's not good
we like to see noisy corrections that
are showing us that we are correcting
and clean moves up okay so when we go
down we will we like to go down with
like you know some ups and downs
on low volume but whenever we go up we
want it to be clear on high volume and
big moves okay so here it does first
impulse was perfect but this second wave
is not looking like a second wave look
at that guys it's just you know selling
selling selling so i don't know where
it's where it's gonna stop um
my analysis in my analysis and last
video i was saying that i was expecting
uh a second wave going to 21. uh i
didn't want to see anything below 21
because the 21 is was the 61.8 percent
ratio below that level everything can
happen
we can still come back but most likely
whenever we go below the 61.8 percent
fib ratio the probability of a strong
and massive third wave is decreasing a
lot okay so right
right now we end the situation we're in
this situation already on friday i was
still expecting that the 19 level holds
because um i was talking about some
access that could happen because that's
true uh technical analysis gives you
guys some areas but then the market
does what he wants to do and here i was
expecting that maybe we're gonna go to
uh 19 which is the bottom of this fourth
wave once again second waves guys uh
like to go to the top of the third
bottom of the fourth uh preceding subway
so whenever you have a strong impulse
try to find one two three four five
bottom of the fourth top of the third
and usually this is where the second
wave pullback is going to here uh the
the 19 level was the bottom of the force
wave so let me zoom in here a little bit
because once again guys uh my analysis
was off and i totally uh accept it and
and you know it's uh i'm sorry that i
didn't give you this scenario but i was
not expecting that it's not uh something
that i think was expected
uh to see this you know very brutal move
down but what is interesting and i want
to focus on that is that the supports
and resistances i'm giving you guys are
acting very well and you can check in my
videos i always give it before because i
find them using the past price action so
here as you can see 19 we had a positive
reaction first here um
then
we went to this trend line this year
this yellow trend land that is here and
i'm going to talk about this yellow
trend line by the way because we have
some information coming from here and
this is the same information we need to
use for later so i'm going to show that
in one minute uh we got here we found
some support first at 19 then got
rejected on this yellow tree land that i
get connecting the highs using the
logarithmic scale the the highs of the
move down which is also the 20 hours
moving average i'm here using the hourly
time frame guys we got projected here
then bam went through the 19 level okay
um so then this was a breakout then as
you can see we got rejected at 19 and
then we moved lower then here we
consolidated
just below the stream line so i really
liked to see that i was happy when i saw
that this was yesterday
and we had the breakout guys above this
hero trend line so whenever we have a
nice consolidation it's not a perfect
consideration but it's a nice
consideration five candles you know
knocking at the door testing the trend
line is what we want to see
and then we have a breakout
uh this is a good situation but you need
to have a volume increase and you need
to have some momentum information that
is bullish as well so here when you look
at the volume
up i'm putting that bar here we don't
have any volume increase okay so this
breakout is not reliable first thing
second thing uh we like to have a
momentum information so either rsi above
50 or a crossover with the 20 period
moving average uh using the right time
frame i'm not gonna explain here how to
use the right time frame whenever you
trade breakouts if you're interested to
know more about that guys i built a
whole course about that and by the way
thank you very much for those who took
the course and i'm very happy to see
that you guys enjoy it a lot so for
those who didn't take the course yet
click on the link in description of this
video you can now have some monthly
payments so um it's more affordable and
once again all of those who took the
course all the feedbacks i have thank
you so much guys because i put so much
energy in that and i'm really happy to
see that it's helpful for you and here
those who took the course they know that
this breakout is not good quality i'm
explaining how to find the good
breakouts because once again this is the
only way for me to make money in swing
trading
let's be honest i lost money on amc
in the past week but i made money on the
rest of the market and overall i'm flat
guys for the past two weeks i didn't
make money i made a good money in the
first month
but then i put
some money on in amc and gme which for
now didn't work but i can tell you guys
that i'm going to keep doing that and
whenever i see a nice opportunity
on amc i will each time build a strong
bullish position uh that is gonna one
day deliver a very very nice profit uh
if this quiz happens and i really
believe it's gonna happen sooner or
later so let's go back here to what is
happening right now so yeah we have this
breakout with that volume and we test it
again this morning the 19 level and bam
brutally rejected guys bears just
reminded us that they are in full
control so right now we are sliding on
this trend line that was resistance
which is now support but it's a support
that is
dropping all right so it's not a support
that is really usable to trade uh but
we're sliding on it the next report is
16.3 because once again
i told you guys that i was expecting a
bounce around 21 or even 26 it didn't
happen
but something that is still very
interesting to have is all those
supports so right now the next one is
16.3 each time one of them has been
broken we went to the next one uh and
each time we went to the next one we had
a positive reaction first as you can see
here for all the supports i'm having
here guys that each time give a positive
reaction and right now what i can tell
you is that i think we're gonna go to
16.3 but i don't know um if we go there
i believe that we're gonna have a
bullish reaction maybe then we're gonna
break it below i don't know but at some
point every move needs to correct up or
down we are moving down for a long time
uh so at some point we're gonna have a
bullish reaction but right now
the third wave probability has decreased
a lot
once again because we are below the 61.8
fib ratio so now we're gonna have a
resistance area that is created by all
those previous supports when the support
is broken it becomes resistance and now
those resistances guys they're not going
to be easy to go through
um
so
once again it's still possible that
suddenly we have a massive third wave uh
above the 32 point the 30 level that
would be the confirmation we are in the
third wave
but most likely we're gonna need to
consolidate date and once again first
find the bottom for now we are dropping
every day so first thing we need to find
the bottom and we need to consolidate so
ideally i would like maybe to go to 16.3
then rebound and then i don't know maybe
get rejected at 22 ideally 26 i doubt we
can go above 26 in uh one move right now
and find some you know some area to
consolidate i don't know exactly where
it can be ideally the closer to the 32
level the better but it can be anywhere
else
let me show you what we're looking for
guys bam
uh we're looking for basically exactly
what happened here so let me remind you
maybe what happened here guys because
this is again what we're looking for
we're looking for some bullish signals
to buy this is once again the technique
that i've been using during my career i
guess for a very long time uh this is
the technique that i believe is the
right way to do some swing training is
to wait for
bullish
signal and here for example look at this
move down okay this is one move down
okay and in this move down i remember so
here i was bullish guys and we had a
downside breakout
and then i told you we need time we need
to consolidate so right now we are a
little bit in the same situation and the
consideration happened here guys okay so
you can see we move down then we move
sideways okay
so in this consolidation i was looking
for a breakout there was some fake outs
but i was looking for a breakout which
is a move across a resistance that is
obvious and that is happening on
increasing volume and it happened guys
here on the 22nd of march and you can
check guys in my discord
i'm posting every day those amc recap
bam bam bam so you can see on the 22nd
of march
it's here bam 22nd of march i posted
this chart for the first time since feb
10 we have a breakout with a nice volume
increase okay guys so this was the
signal that things will probably start
to look much better so right now we're
looking a little bit for the same thing
so
once again first we need to find the
bottom uh 16.3 is the next support but
there is no guarantee it holds i believe
that at some point we're going to have a
massive bullish reaction
i had a plan to buy call options i lost
money on that uh
definitely but once again i made money
guys on silver and i made money on a
crude oil i'm going to show you quickly
how
very soon but first um yeah i'm going to
keep buying here
so that at least i have my position
built for a potential squeeze but then
i'm not gonna keep buying next week
because now the productive third wave
happens is much lower so what i'm gonna
do i'm having my positions i'm still
having my shares uh so i'm happy uh if
we drop i lose money but as long as i
don't sell i don't lose uh so i can keep
that position a very very long time i'm
totally fine with that and michael my
call options position is going to expire
roughly between april so the april
options i think they're going to expire
worthless but may june july i have
options until then
and here what i'm going to be looking
for guys is some consideration so once
again first we find the bottom then we
consolidate i don't know where ideally
we would like to consider it a little
bit here and go here to test this major
resistance because once again you guys
saw this move down
okay so this is one move down that
happens in one two okay then
consolidation first we move down okay
let me show you again we move down then
we consolidate then we have a breakout
with volume increase okay so we're
looking for the same thing
but on the higher time frame okay now we
are looking for the same thing here okay
so we move down
we consolidate and we want to have this
consideration as close as possible to
the resistance
trendline which is very obviously here
now it was not short before
because i could use the regular scale
all the log scale now it's sure that
it's this resistance line is found using
the log scale gas and you can check by
yourself because it's the one that is
giving me the best reactions here so we
want to see now uh this consolation
taking place below this level so for now
we're still dropping we're going to
consolidate i don't know we're going to
find the bottom we're going to bounce i
think that then we're gonna be rejected
uh somewhere between 26 and 32 even
maybe before i don't know but we're
going to be looking for this
consolidation that is going to tell us
where the bears are located then we're
going to need to have a breakout above
that level on increasing volume and this
is gonna be the signal that we are ready
to strongly move higher again and at
that time i will be here again to tell
you guys and i will be here to uh build
again a long position
uh now what i wanted to show quickly
guys is uh once again because you see me
uh talking about amc and jamie nonstop
because once again this is what you guys
want to see but i just want to make very
clear guys that the techniques i'm using
that i've been using for a very long
time are very efficient and i would say
classic assets okay um like oil uh the
triple q
um
silver all those assets where you have a
lot of traders using those techniques
that are involved in the trade and here
guys i today i make good money guys on
oil because as you can see here guys and
for those who want to join the discord
uh just click on the link in description
of this video guys john the goal the
platinum membership
in the platinum membership guys i share
all the trades i do so you cannot say uh
that you know i'm not giving you the
best i can guys i'm sharing every trade
i do and here guys you you have all my
trades here
and as you can see bam-bam-bam some main
trades about amc uh but here
i did the trade okay uso so this was uh
on april 1st i bought some 80 calls and
most more recently
okay here so this was april sevens guys
i bought uh some u.s socials at
7100 uso shares and of um you usually
using a stop loss guess i shot my
stop-loss here as well and as you can
see uso touched 70.
72 in aftermarket i got executed in
aftermarket and then we moved to sony
higher and i believe this is only the
beginning as in this is how i'm going to
make my money to reinvest in amc and gme
same things guys for silver those who i
hope that some of you managed to catch
this silver trade bam bam bam where did
i post it
so it is here
okay here
silver
no here okay we increased our position
on silver so i had already bought silver
live with you guys uh when i was in
panama i increased my position uh so
this was on april 1st as well i
increased my position i would i bought
some 28 calls uh and
right now those positions those two
positions today uh help me to cover the
loss of amc so i have a very decent
position in amc but i'm still not losing
money today thanks to those two
positions that helped me to generate
profits and here what method method did
i use as usual guys uh breakout with
increase in volume and then uh so here
it was a false wave um and then we buy
on the pullback right i did exactly the
same thing here guys and this is what i
tried to do on amc it didn't work but i
just want to make clear guys that um you
know those techniques they work when
whenever you do that
many times and you select the best
signals which which is what i'm trying
to do which which is what i'm trying to
share with you in this code and here
today uh silver and oil helped me to
cover the losses of amc so to conclude
guys uh bam bam bam
uh we are not looking good on amc we now
uh need to consolidate uh fi first find
the bottom then consolidate then we're
gonna be able to try to find some uh
breakout levels uh
at some point we're gonna have a bullish
reaction i'm gonna keep buying guys i'm
gonna still keep i'm gonna stick to my
plan i'm gonna keep buying options uh
tomorrow and friday uh right now those
options are worth very little so you
know it's um you can buy more
so that's good uh at some point if we
manage to move higher uh later
and uh i don't think the third wave
right now can happen without the
consideration uh because this doesn't
look like a one two so i think we're
going to consider it somewhere so
hopefully the the closer to this trend
line and then we're going to have a
breakout with increasing volume and this
is going to be the signal that we are
ready to squeeze so and on gme we're
looking much better so let's see uh
jamie one can once again uh maybe take
amc with with it um
and and we we can at any time at any
time we can see this strong moves up
happening on jme so let's see maybe it's
gonna start from here again so that's it
for today i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys